ils sont partis ce matin à 10 heures de
joué-lès-tours direction blois orléans
puis paris une partie des participants
ont convoi de la liberté venus du
sud-ouest de la france ont fait une
escale la nuit dernière dans la
métropole tourangelle des voitures des
camions ou des camping cars sur place
d'anciens gilet jaune des retraités des
antilles passe ou tout simplement des
citoyens lambda qui ont du mal à boucler
les fins de mois tristan weekly a passé
une partie de la nuit avec eux regardez
sous un concert de klaxons et de feux
d'artifice
un cortège de plus d'une centaine de
voitures et camions entrent sur le
parking de l'espace malraux à
joué-lès-tours pour les accueillir plus
de 300 tourangeaux sont sur place le
convoi est parti plus tôt dans la
journée de poitiers et du sud ouest de
la france
du coup on vient de bordeaux en fin de
vie nord de bordeaux en fait on est
parti ce matin à 10 heures de sainte
eulalie on dort ici ce soir et on repart
demain là on va dormir dans un camion si
on peut aller jusqu'à paris on va
essayer de suivre le mouvement c'est
très fraternel c'est au sens l'amour
partout les gens nous applaudissent ils
nous disent merci
il nous apporte plein de victuailles
voilà en nous un espoir de changer
l'ambiance est détendue conviviale
sur un fond de colère sourde
[Applaudissements]
ces gilets jaunes anti passe ou simples
citoyens demandent la fin du pass
vaccinale et dénonce la perte du pouvoir
d'achat lié aux inflation fait de ne
plus avoir de liberté
avec tout ce que instaure le
gouvernement en parlant de
deux des vaccins avec des passeports
vaccinaux d'aider toutes ces conneries
et c'est pas qu'une histoire de maladie
les lun on nous enlève les libertés sur
tous les autres font à l'est les laits
tout ce qui arrive avec l'essence tout
ce qui arrive bientôt et l'électricité
qu'il faut qu'ils arrêtent parce que ça
va ça va mal finir cette affaire tous
ont passé la nuit ici objectif du convoi
inspiré de celui né au canada rejoindre
les autres manifestants à paris puis
bruxelles dans ces deux villes les
manifestations sont interdites jusqu'à
lundi